mais oui oui j'avais ce qu'il fait dans
cette émission il regarde tout ce qui se
passe en or il regarde ce qui se passe
pendant les pubs il regarde il voit même
des choses qui se passe pendant
l'émission que je ne vois pas que
personne ne voit c'est l'oeil de jean
luc lemoine
j'aime comment vous présenter cette
rubrique merci jean luc on a une
question mais oui tant qu'à faire
allons-y remis en question bonjour je
m'appelle meti je déteste votre rubrique
car chaque semaine vous fait passer vos
collègues pour des idiots est ce que
pour une fois vous pourriez essayer de
les mettre en valeur espèce de trou du
cul
vous avez raison betty je n'ai pas fait
mes collègues en valeur et c'est injuste
car je voudrais pas me lancer des fleurs
mais il adore ma rubrique surtout jean
michel en quatrième partie des missions
et on l'attend tous les jeudis cette
quatrième partie on sait que vous êtes
très nombreux à être friand de jean luc
lemoine est friand
s'arrête jamais le centre m'a dit tu vas
avoir des complexes
je suis pas friand je suis au régime oui
aujourd'hui je vais rendre hommage au
talent de mes camarades donc à commencer
par thierry et l'humour et bien ce soir
je vais vous montrer la face cachée du
génie il ya quelques semaines
toute l'équipe avait décidé de porter
une frange à commencer par le plus beau
d'entre nous bonjour cyril qui est quand
même le seul mec à penser qu'il écrivait
qu'une perruque
regardez comme il a l'air sérieux après
une vague de thierry on peut dire vive
la république vive la france on va
revenir sur tout ce qui s'est passé à la
télé mais presque la coupe du chanteur
d'indochine mais il croit qu'il peut
présenter le jt quand vous noterez au
passage d'ailleurs excéder cette journée
qu'avec une frange regardez bien c'est
dingue ce qu isabelle morini-bosc
ressemble à isabelle morini-bosc
saisissante
c'est la même donc thierry allait oser
vivre la frange jamais pas eh bien ne
croyez pas que ce jeune homme est venu
tout seul
non il le préparait depuis la veille
j'ai même les images de sa réflexion je
vous préviens ça m'attriste parce que le
mec il parle tout seul
olala c'est la paix
qui fait de la paix la tristesse oui
tiens est un génie et et ce qui est plus
étonnant c'est que thierry a des fans of
donc pour leur faire plaisir à tous les
trois je vais vous faire une petite
compil de ces mini prix ceux qui ne sont
pas passés à l'antenne parce qu'il ya
pas de raison qu'on soit les seuls à
souffrir
vous apprécierez au passage la qualité
des saillies quel que soit le sujet et
surtout les réactions juste après
on a réduit l'invité ce matin aurait pas
ce que c'est l'amie du petit déjeuner le
garage qu'ils ont championnat c'est bien
c'est qui ce avérage des gaules
il n'aura qu'à revenir dessus nous
saurons vous devez faire
le coup moi je sais pourquoi me camoufle
un peu à se regarder tomber tout ça si
les guichets
justice et je tiens mon humour
je sais que je tiens moore dans thierry
arrive
avec son but complexe andré hamel et
même structure familiale et ahmed jan la
fois elle se dit vraiment mais pourquoi
illégaux comme ça c'est simple vous
pouvez tout dire ici c'est drôle d'effet
il vous fait rire mais les vous
entretenir avec l'humoriste
il vous fait rire thierry moreau hamel
merci elle est tellement gentil qu'elle
n'ose pas le dire mais c'est drôle parce
que c'est pas drôle en fait des fois que
ça me fait rire c'est comique de
répétition comme il y en a plein qui
font pas les méchants
tous les jours c'est un peu chiant il a
raison enfin il explique qu'il est drôle
parce qu'il ya dans thiery yari effet
avec à y donc c'est pour ça que thierry
avec thierry enfin surtout jean michel
jean michel c'est pierce qui l'accès à
côté et là je vais vous dire qu'il
commence à craquer
la preuve
vous aimez les histoires qu'ils sont
drôles qui le prend la mesure niveaux
séparent ou séparément
ce niveau les manchettes of china
par exemple en fond sonore
la meilleure joueuse bello
allez go pour cette interruption
involontaire de l'élégance privé sur
l'air vraiment mais bon j'ai promis
aujourd'hui de mettre en valeur mes
camarades je vais commencer à tout
seigneur tout honneur cyril qui est un
patron hors pair je dis je le dis je
vais pas prendre le boulot de camille
combal 1 mais c'est un patron que nous
vénérons et que je faisais mon flat et
surtout pour son élégance et vous alors
on peut parler de cinq secondes parce
que ce petit gilet comme ça cette
avancée des céréales au nord maintenant
c'est john mack hanouna
j'adore dans cette vallée très molle
fort j'aime beaucoup ça qu'on fait c'est
méchant c'est méchant mais ce succès lui
c'est quand même c'est impossible qui
s'embrouille avec les stylistes car
series s'entend très bien avec nos
stylistes à regarder par exemple notre
styliste chloé qui vient le rhabiller
pendant la publicité
et
la police interroge de l'habitude et
shanghai
c'est vrai la bomba durant tout va bien
c'est vrai que la rtnc je pense que j'ai
fait un petit peu mal je sais pas on va
revoir ça tout de suite
c'est vrai parce que moi je suis un gros
type de sarko boys alors une des
fonctions de cyril aussi dans l'émission
c'est de distribuer la parole elle est
beaucoup de gens nous demandent comment
il fait comment il sait qui va
intervenir
et bien c'est très simple pendant les
magnétos pendant que thierry cherche des
jeux de mots les autres sont des petits
signes comme jean michel vous allez voir
encore une fois un grand moment de
solitude où on s'aperçoit que
jean-michel imiterait bien jacques
chirac
non c'est non non vous avez bien fait de
faire sortir
merci je vis toujours ce que je pense
ouais bon lui l'ancien petit peu trop
laurent fontaine tu es là bas me disent
qu'à regarder la regardez là tout en
chignon tout en chignon commence à rak
c'est quoi cette robe est une petit robe
de soie aouine faudra soit alors elle
part elle part au cortège
alors pourquoi es-tu clé pour les
téléspectateurs en fait je leur ai dit
de lui faire un signe quand c'est pour
donner leur avis ils font juste ça et
quand c'est pour dire une vanne
ils font vais donc là vous aviez une
valse et procèdent je vous ai pas donné
à penser quand même voir ça y est vous
dire exactement ces trucs intelligents
finalement c'est une 'bad bon la fin il
y croit plus du tout donc aujourd'hui
pendant que nous continuons à faire des
petits signes comme gilles verdez vous
allez voir il le fait très bien
jean michel lui il a changé de méthode
souvent des employés en formation
premier presse outre manche
quel traille o c'est le guardian
c'est le gars qui tient son bras mais je
vais vous dire c'est dommage de pas
donner plus la parole à jean michel car
il a plein de choses à nous offrir ce
que j'ignorais c'est qu'il est très calé
en astronomie
il ya déjà un mec qui vous a dragué en
vous montrant les étoiles oui tu vois là
bas c'est la grande ourse
hamel oui vous pouvez sortir avec un mec
comme ça françois renom pourriez sortir
avec un mec comme et vous m'avez déjà
posé la question et mais je vous la
repose non me connaissez mieux n'ont
toujours pas banal on pourrait essayer
de retrouver un petit peu de fraîcheur
dans cette émission nous reste que tu
peux m'aider s'il te plaît j'ai besoin
d'un peu de tendresse à au pays d'accord
alors pas vous vous êtes vous êtes
jeunes arrêtés passait tracera la chan
peu plus des sardines sa mère la fuite
alors vous pouvez tout critiquer sauf
les sardines
jean ii
ça
est fâché fâché je vais tout à l'heure
on parlait d'une interview d'enora de
parts et oui eh bien sachez que c'était
un des moments qui avaient été coupés
aussi
voilà c'est on voulait sauver service
mais n'en fait pas je m'occupais des la
merci mais avant je vais revenir sur
jean michel qui est sans doute le
meilleur d'entre nous même s'il a du mal
à suivre cyril un jour cyril jour une
inspiration comme ça a décidé d'enlever
les buzzer duquel est la question
j'espère ne pas avoir choqué des gens
avec ce mauvais choix oui
il était ça peut arriver il n'avait pas
vu donc deux jours plus tard plus belle
la vie castle et rendez vous en terre
inconnue
je suis désolé ce we are été re on est
pas à l'abri d'une rechute
je voudrais dire du bien de l'équipe il
ya que des deux ne rappelez vous le jour
où cyril avait demandé à chacun d'entre
nous de faire
je sais que ce n'est plus un cri
d'animal alors allez-y gilles verdez
vous allez préparer quoi le cri du lion
séducteur pour isabelle
car malade mais moi et oui je vous dis
ce qui est encore plus drôle c'est la
tête de mort qu'il avait nos
félicitations vous donne la parole aux
xi qu il ya quelque chose qui m'échappe
gilles a comme été rédacteur en chef du
parisien jean-michel va travailler au
figaro thierry directeur de la rédaction
de télé 7 jours
donc oui il ya des ponts entre les
écoles de journalisme et les asiles et
c'est sur c'est sûr et puis il faut deux
cas mais j'ai parce qu'il a raison en
cyril avec ta parade nuptiale tap a
essayé la séduire tu as failli la tuer
regarde
incroyable
on n'écrit pas loin la crise cardiaque
ne faut pas faire ça isabelle pasquet
isabelle elle vit tout avec beaucoup
d'intensité je joue je vous assure elle
nous l'a encore démontré il n'y a pas
longtemps en écoutant cyrille schott et
regardez la bien réagir
les français adorent ces déserts de
samse gier non justement c'est pas des
heures il trouve très vite et c'est ça
qui est grave c'est que il trouve très
vite
oui certes ici c'est comme madame rideau
c'est quand même joli éléments assez
joli les membres s'affaisser ce cas au
dessus de latélec l'antenne c'est une
fourchette pour capter un mort sont
allumées et très jolies
elle est très forte mais vous le savez
là où elle est la meilleure la langue
c'est la danse je sais que c'est bien ça
donc on vraiment rendre hommage à ma
collègue
rien de mieux qu une compile de ses
dernières créations à
camus
série la mérite
pourquoi
dans le trouble dans le pays par des
pipes
les
brrr
deux navires venant à bout
le primate
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment libye
c'est le tir juste avant de voir la
dernière question je dois rappeler amel
bent le nouvel album ça s'appelle
instinct merci d'avoir été avec lui à
belvèze on aime et qui est en tournée
dans toute la france
ahmed ne changeait rien ne changeait
rien un taux de change dans cinq
mais mes amis puis jallet d'accord non
non rien de rien même les amis vous
restez pas et malik bentalha se la
racontent les 23 et 24 mai à la cigale à
paris et mise en scène de l'excellent
mohamed hamidi qu'on en voit souvent on
sculpte avec une dernière question de
jean luc lemoine c'est parti bonjour je
m'appelle yvette alors plus les jours
passent plus souvent les gens de votre
équipe beau et séduisant
donc ma question est la suivante est ce
que vous connaîtriez un bo9 palm os dans
le quartier